[Music]
in bitter billionaire news Oh who
submitted by Bart's parts get out of
here yeah gross you know I have been
about three years sober from his life
maybe you smell it again anonymous it's
like a driver's license you need to find
keep going back to be a part of the East
Bella - you have to do the [ __ ] nose
checking everything to see if you're
good in a bitter divorce battle a
billionaire got revenge on his ex-wife
with spray vandal spring farts break oh
I thought pepper spray no fart spray oh
my god remember that disgusting a spray
that we smelled during JK parties yeah
like ass
yeah it's called a spray a three
complete I take out the memories of what
happens on just King party oh good so
we'll do it again you won't even know
just never get divorced or sign a
prenuptial agreement uh but you don't
get [ __ ] you're a billionaire just marry
another billionaire well then still sign
a prenup jay-z and Beyonce yeah but then
make sure like they're the same
billionaire or like she has more money
than you yeah then you don't really you
kind of [ __ ] up we're not married I'm
gonna roast her before you can that's my
job Turner roaster they're trying to
roast my girlfriend [ __ ] yeah what no
you're not gonna beat her I'm gonna beat
her that's real love like somebody
somebody's trying to like come up and in
like fight her at the club and sure we
got it the slap across the face [ __ ]
[ __ ] you guys try [ __ ] that yeah you
don't touch my part just don't hit her
at all and just hug her not you
no one does it what this guy a
billionaire for so he is an investor
fund manager and philanthropist crane to
his video they don't make money by being
a philanthropist you give money homie I
mean that's what the Wikipedia page
every rich person is a philanthropist
it's a good tax write-off all right so
this dude he's from California he needs
a new wife yeah he's getting a divorce
with his wife - so this is Bill his name
is Bill Gross when I see heads like that
I I I'm really curious where the hair
line starts like in the middle of the
head it starts right here and I think it
looks like he's always just had a big
forehead that's the biggest one I've
ever seen though yeah in younger guys
that have like a big forehead but attend
they reached this age their foreheads
are like it just it just looks like it
receded because the age but I think he
just has his hair he just always had a
big forehead or it just looked like his
eyebrows and eyes just traveled down his
face throughout the years he looks like
an egg with the hair from the back hey
you don't talk about my billionaire
friend Bill Gross yeah you guys are pros
my future husband
I know yeah but [ __ ] by him for a
billion dollars nobody put that on the
table get the billion dollars but you
get to share it that's just as good for
me yeah ten million I have to stay with
her I don't care about money I care
about things I think I could date a lot
of nice things bad don't care about
money yeah so when Bill was leaving his
home which is worth about thirty six
million dollars we're gonna be [ __ ]
poor ass that's a lot of [ __ ] POG me
man yeah what I got like eight tennis
courts oh you talk just like the
homeless people
it's wild your house have a tennis
complex I like that's how I calculate
like he appraised the house let me see
what that's about a tennis court I know
how much for tennis courts are worth
that's about eight is a regular
houseboat eight in the back it's just Oh
buddy it's a two-bedroom condo I want to
see the [ __ ] bird's-eye view of the
house of the property [ __ ] a little God
is [ __ ] like scattered they're not
even like late to get like bricks
they're just [ __ ] like this oh my god
I really want you to get [ __ ] filthy
rich dude oh yeah a backyards on a pond
and a bunch of Mexicans that's MacArthur
Park bro that's what I picture the
landscape it's gonna be a he's like not
Murr it's the only reference I have you
just have a park and it's not yours so
anyway when he was leaving he left the
home in quote a state of utter chaos and
disrepair and so apparently when he was
leaving he just [ __ ] up the whole
house that's a lot of house to [ __ ] up
he used these sprays he's sprayed it on
the houseplants and he also had an army
of spies where they were spying on the
wife and anyone around the wife put it
those other billionaires this will apply
some sore ass fingers look it's
squeezing that [ __ ] all day God oh dude
those small ones after you use it it
gets hella tiring you're right [ __ ]
clean your whole house with Windex -
[ __ ] your fingers get Soros Club you
guys ever do this and get tired and then
you start using your thumb yeah
you've gotten doing it like a [ __ ] like
a cowboy revolver [ __ ] you got a rush is
so true I would just [ __ ] take the
top off and you kids without hamadan
though you don't know my B's adult
struggles and [ __ ] yeah apparently he
even left dead fish in the air vent gas
all petty what does she do achieve it or
does she kill him well I don't think she
would get anything if she cheated oh
yeah that's right infidelity issues is
guilty of dry hair well she left him
right go to the pigs you ever get so
good guilty for dry hair that's what
dude she looks great in survival you
don't want to use conditioner then this
and this she was part of his [ __ ] they
look so happy for it to be so bitter
tender oh good it's not happy you know
why look at the way he's holding her
hand there's no passion in that
relationship
yeah innervated they weren't having so I
got Stepford [ __ ] does that see they had
two separate bedrooms like that we have
two separate bedrooms I already know
about your weight no you're facing down
yeah
remember that one time we're not doing a
dog star and I got tired and I just Paul
I pulled out songs about the nut and I
stuck it in and I went like this one and
then you got to finish
oh yeah I'll give this to you did you
yeah you need that
yes--she put this on your mouth god
you're like I'm gonna put you at hey I'm
a gentleman huh
I make sure you finish first all the
time that's good yeah we we use a dildo
for her last time she's gonna be on JK
beers by the way what oh you guys get
these plastic penis shaped things away
from I finish too fast so we have a
dildo for her I'm not gonna let you
roast me today it's fun when she run for
you I know but then it's not fun when my
feelings got hurt yeah this is making
headlines cause he's a [ __ ]
billionaire he's so petty that he's
going to these extremes he's been
married to that woman's in 1985 yeah
that was before I was before I was born
all right all right [ __ ] pump the
brake so I was an infant years old an
infant years old less than a year damn
us [ __ ] long time it was like five
you just lost me homegirl until the next
video
okay I'm gonna born yet at all no not at
all I was born in the 90s yep that's
right
good morning 2002 I'm so shocked thank
you you see knew about X constancy on
before we did yep extant the Khans
testicle alright peeps extreme tenta con
yep this guy reminds me of a textbook
billionaire store
let's also focus on the fact that his
last name is gross and he's doing wrong
check it out so this is kind of what I'm
thinking right so if I'm a billionaire
now I'm pretty much set their generation
after me is pretty much set okay so why
the [ __ ] would I care if I want to do
some petty [ __ ] I got the time to do it
[ __ ] it I have a question it but you
would do it on a bigger scale like I
would at least that's the thing how did
I become a millionaire a billionaire
that I would buy you know those hands
you know that's the [ __ ] hand claws
yeah then I'll put a spray each one of
those hand claws I'd squeeze it once and
it sprays all of them so don't do
anything else you just yeah have you
ever seen five sprays come out at the
same time just the same [ __ ] without you
literally did the equivalent of what my
parents gave me vanilla ice cream and
they asked me if I wanted new ice cream
and they just put a cherry on top of it
that's all you did
it was the same [ __ ] he did nothing to
disprove it yeah I would have liked
[ __ ] buried some dead parts inside
the walls or something made [ __ ] you can
find all these things
[Music]